it's crazy because I talked to Payne and
he had told me that you had offered him
a record deal super early and he said
that uh a major label came and offered
him like a substantially crazier amount
of money they did but he said I I
trusted Akon I believed in his movement
to and he's like I'm living out my car
me and my girl are struggling he's like
and I passed on the bag with this major
situation and stuck with Akon and signed
the deal for less money because of his
vision because of all the things that
you bring to the table that money can't
buy like uh what was it about paying
obviously he was in a group called uh
was it the Nappy Heads yeah robbery is
my [ __ ] by the way that's a Tampa
classic
um but uh what was it about paying that
like initially kind of struck your
interest and had you kind of take a
chance on him and he also took a chance
on you no he did I mean until his day I
thank him for just believing in me
because that kind of changed your label
he was the first artist I signed on
right he was like literally the first
artist so it was not only because he was
the first artist that I had to prove for
future artists that I plan to sign but
because he took the chance on me I made
sure that I put whatever I had in him
like because I I gave him a promise that
I'm gonna give you a career I said I
know they could give you a bag but I'm
gonna give you a career I'm gonna give
you a career and I made sure that that
happened for him until this day I still
fight for him even though he's often
doing his own thing I always will always
be in debt to T-Pain for sure yeah pop
pop the conflict music off the label as
a label no without a doubt it was our
franchise player